If you don't have anything to look up
to,
you don't have anything to do,
right?
A lot of the meaning that people find in
their lives is purpose driven.
And in order to put effort into
something,
to work towards something,
you have to assume axiomatically that
what you're working towards is better
than what you have because why else
would you do it?
And there's a relationship,
like if it's way better than what you
have,
it's obviously proportionally difficult.
So you try to balance difficulty with,
with positivity,
let's say something like that.
But you're always aiming up if you're
aiming and if you're not aiming,
then you don't really have any purpose.
And that deprives your life of meaning.
And that's not good.
Because if your life is deprived of
meaning,
then what you're left with is the
suffering.
It's not neutral,
right?
It's negative.
So now the problem with having to a mop
is that that produces a hierarchy,
right?
Because if you pause it an aim,
then everyone a raise themselves along a
hierarchy of better at it,
to worse at it,
right?
And it doesn't matter.
Like if,
if you,
if you create basketball as a game a
hundred years later,
you create people who are hyper
specialized at basketball and they're
great at it and virtually everyone else
is bad.
So it doesn't matter.
As soon as you produced a value,
a value proposition,
you produce a hierarchy.
The problem with the hierarchy is it
produces inequality.
The problem with inequality is it
produces resentment,
right?
But you can't get rid of the damn
hierarchy because they produce
inequality and resentment because then
you don't have anywhere to go.
So that's not an answer.
Okay?
So let's say you're trying to deal with
the fact that you have to put up with a
hierarchy.
If you're going to have any values,
well,
how do you escape from the resentment
trap?
And the answer is you do an intelligent
multidimensional analysis of your life.
It's like,
by the time you're 30 I would say you're
a pretty singular person.
You know,
you're,
you're unique in particular and your
life has multiple dimensions and you're
more or less successful,
or not along many of those dimensions,
but it's completely ridiculous game to
pick someone else arbitrarily who's
doing much better than you on one of
those dimensions,
to assume that you're a failure because
of that or that the world is unfair
because of that,
without knowing in full detail all of
the rest of the elements of their lives.
I mean,
look,
we're absolutely the awash in stories of
unhappy celebrities.
You know,
[inaudible] an interminable divorces or
an in affairs or in addictions or,
and that's par for the course.
It's not helpful.
It's helpful to have a goal.
It's necessary to have a hierarchy.
It's not particularly useful to compare
yourself to other people,
but it is useful.
Compare yourself to yourself.
That's the right baseline,
right?
That's takes everything else into
account and,
and it's really practically useful.
And I,
I've done this in my clinical practice
very frequently.
It's like,
okay,
let's take stock of where you are.
Okay?
And then let's,
let's hypothesize about where you would
like to be.
It's a complex conversation,
right?
Because we want to figure out what's not
so good about your present situation.
Exactly.
Precisely.
And then come up with a hypothesis about
what your life would look like if it was
better.
And then we can work on incremental
improvement.
No idea would be,
there's some step you could take that
you would take that would make today or
tomorrow fractionally better than
yesterday.
Right?
And then you can iterate that and that's
actually unbelievably powerful.
[inaudible]
you hit the effect of compounding
interest,
let's say very,
very rapidly if you do that.
Yeah,
well,
so there's real utility and incremental
progress and you don't have to improve
your life much in increments to start
hitting the effect of compounding
interest.
You know,
you make one thing slightly better and
that increases the probability that
you'll make the next things slightly
better as well as having its positive
side effects.
And so if you,
even if you make small steps forward and
you do that regularly,
that can turn your life around very
rapidly over like a one to two year
period.
I mean,
that's a long time,
one to two years.
But it's not a lifetime and it certainly
beats the hell out of going downhill
precipitously,
which tends to be the alternative.
So it's better and it keeps you out of
the resentment,
you know?
And it's also more realistic because
it's not like,
it's not like everyone else doesn't have
their problems.
You know,
we,
we have these fictitious successful
people that it's easy for us to compare
ourselves to detrimentally and to become
jealous and bitter about that,
but also to be very hard on ourselves
because we're not successful.
It's like if you talk to successful
people,
let's say,
and I'm not trying to say that there's
no such thing as genuine accomplishment
because obviously there is,
but people,
even people who are successful have
lives that are very difficult and you
know,
they have,
uh,
an ill family member or aged parents or,
or they're suffering from some serious
illness themselves,
which is very,
very common.
Or they have a psychological problem
that's not trivial or they have a
traumatic past.
It's like life is brutal.
And,
and becoming resentful about your
relative position is a way to make it
more brutal.
It's not helpful to you and it's not
helpful to anyone else.
Yeah.